Research carried out at three London hospitals suggests nearly one in three women...
...suffered post-traumatic stress one month after a loss.
Some women's symptoms improved over time,...
...but one in six women still had post-traumatic stress after nine months.
Most women are never diagnosed or treated.
Well, the most common symptoms are flashbacks,...
...so people are getting flashbacks of the event,...
...re-experiencing what actually happened to them perhaps.
I think it can be incredibly destructive.
At the moment, screening isn't happening, and I don't think,...
...I think people are constantly slipping through the net.
It differs throughout the world.
I think the challenges are the same.
You have lost a baby at the end of the day,...
...and I think the core issue is that in the end,...
...I think a lot of these people all around the world are suffering very similarly.
We're in this beautiful meadow.
I can see a couple of stags in the distance.
This is one potential solution being developed...
...by Professor Bourne and his team in the UK...
...to try and make what can be a very traumatic experience more bearable.
This is a virtual reality headset that we are offering women...
...who need to have a procedure to remove pregnancy tissue when they've miscarried,...
...to transport them to sort of a more calm virtual reality world...
...for distraction from the pain and anxiety during the procedure.